all right we're now live and the topic
that I've picked for this month's
philosophy pop-ups is back to school the
philosophical texts that I'm teaching so
I'm talking about the three classes that
I'll be teaching here in Milwaukee two
of them at Marquette University one at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
so I'll talk in just a little bit about
which text those are as more and more
viewers arrive so I'm going to end this
one at the top of the hour because I've
got to walk the dogs and then go out and
meet with a client a little bit later
today
but I think we'll have plenty of time to
talk about what texts I'm teaching and
why I pick those texts in particular for
the classes I'm teaching so let me tell
you first about what classes I've got
lined up so I'm teaching for Marquette
University who I taught for last fall as
well then I was teaching ethics this
time I was slated to teach two sections
of their new foundations in philosophy
they've changed their core curriculum
they got rid of the required ethics
class for incoming students and sort of
consolidated that into this foundations
class which you could think of as
essentially like an intro to philosophy
class with a few other things added in
and designed by committee so you know
you know how things are when they go
through committee there's a lot of
compromises and a lot of things that we
have to do I actually have to go
tomorrow to a meeting where they'll tell
us how we're supposed to teach it or
something along those lines and we had
to fill out a checklist and your
syllabus had to have these things in it
and those things in it so it was quite
an interesting exercise but I've got the
syllabus ready for it I've got the
picked out there mostly loaded into the
course management system so that is all
taken care of
yeah and then what else I'm teaching
business ethics from our Kent as well
and business ethics is going to be
primarily for students who have already
had ethics so I can presume that they
actually have quite a good background in
the material and we can like go on to
applied issues and a bit of review and
things along those lines and then I'm
teaching this philosophies of human
nature for my ad the Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design and that is a
different school so Marquette is you
know a major research university that
educates a lot of undergraduates and
that that's what I'll be helping with
they're my ed is a professional school
it is the School of Art and Design
here in Milwaukee it actually has a
nationwide reputation and so these are
these are students who are there
primarily for those majors you know
either the fine arts you know sculpture
painting drawing all that sort of stuff
or they're doing design and I would say
there's probably about twice as many
design students as there are fine arts
they have a really great program I've
been quite impressed with with the
faculty meetings that I've gone to and
all the cool stuff that they're they're
doing they're they're very
student-centered so for these two
classes the philosophical foundations
and the MIAD philosophies of human
nature there is some overlap in what I'm
going to be teaching which is good
because it means I don't have to do
quite so much prep but they are in a
different format you know the Marquette
is a regular meets twice a week
the MIAD meets one time a week for about
two and a half hours and the my ed
students they can't be expected to do
quite as much reading because
you know a lot of the classes are taking
our pretty intensive studio classes so
they don't have as much time so I'm
creating different different texts
different selections but we're starting
off both of them with Plato's apology
and in the my add class I'm actually
also having them read the Republic book
seven allegory of the cave business and
then we're going to read some of plato's
stuff in republic book 10 which if
you've read you know that plato was
pretty hostile to the poets and the
artists and he saw them as merely
engaging in imitation of imitation so
we're gonna discuss that and they're you
know they may have some strong reactions
against it well we'll see how we can
work that in then we're moving to
Aristotle and in the Marquette class
will be doing politics book one I've
actually been shooting some videos on
that recently and then in the other
class we're not doing politics but we're
jumping straight into the Nick and
McCann ethics and we're gonna do more of
the Nicomachean ethics in the Marquette
class the foundations class than in the
Maya class we're just spending one week
on Aristotle in the Mayan class but
about two weeks in the Marquette class
then in both classes we are doing some
Cicero and the reason why we're doing
Cicero is so that we get epicurean and
stoic perspectives so we're looking at
one of his works that has very good
representation of both of them on the
end sometimes translated is on moral
ends and you know again they're gonna
read less of it in the in the my ed
class than in the Marquette class but
we're not gonna read the whole of it
we're gonna read parts of it in both
classes and then we're gonna read an
even bigger book we're gonna read
Augustine City of God but we're only
reading stuff from books 5 11 and 19 and
a lot of that has to do with these
issues that have been brought up already
in terms of like the virtues and human
nature but Augustine makes this argument
that you know the the virtues of the
Hagen's are splendid vices so we're
gonna we're gonna look at that and some
issues about you know free will and some
issues about creation and time and
eternity and then we're jumping way way
forward we're going all the way to
Descartes Oh actually I do have to point
out before we do that in the Marquette
foundations class we're delving very
briefly into some Chinese philosophy
we're gonna look at the daodejing
and the Confucian Analects and if time
permits the book book of filial piety
there is a non Western component
requirement for that class so I picked
some some Chinese philosophy I thought
there would be a nice counterpoint in
the Mayan class we're not doing that so
in both classes then we're jumping to
Rene Descartes and the discourse on
method I tried with the idea of doing
the meditations but I thought and it's a
little bit longer there's a bit more
involved there and I do want to get
through a lot of different perspectives
over the course of the semester so this
course is pretty good and the discourse
also has some some cool speculations
about what makes us human as opposed to
animals or machines then again in both
classes we're doing Thomas Hobbes I
think yeah I should actually check the
syllabus I know we're doing Thomas yeah
we are doing Thomas Hobbes in both
classes and then in the foundations
class who are we doing next I think we I
think we're doing Rousseau in that we
are doing Rousseau definitely in the
other class the the my ed class let me
just check here very quickly sometimes I
get them a little bit mixed up yeah and
so we're gonna do Rousseau we're also
gonna do Mary Wollstonecraft somebody
who I've taught a number of times and
and really enjoy and the students you
know once they get past the the
vocabulary they often tend to
enjoy it quite a bit here here we go
here's my syllabus who else do we have
in there oh we're not doing Rousseau for
for the Marquette class we are doing
that for the my ed class will be doing
Russo's discourse on the origin of
inequality and then in the in the
Marquette class we're doing Syrian
Kierkegaard's fear and trembling which
we won't be doing in the MyID class
there is a little bit of overlap in the
Marquette class s then we're doing some
more existentialist stuff with with
sart's existentialism is a humanism nice
short piece picking back up with with
some existentialist and feminist views
with Simone de Beauvoir is the second
sex and then we're finishing up with
Eichmann in Jerusalem by Hana or rent
and we're doing quite a few of those in
the my ed class as well but the my ed
class is also including some other stuff
that I think the students are really
going to find interesting we're gonna
beer going to be reading real cos
letters to a young poet and that's gonna
represent some of the existentialist
stuff I think that could be quite useful
for them since they are artists and and
I think the stuff about solitude should
be particularly interesting for them as
well Oh in the my ed class we're also
reading Marx is alienated labor maybe a
little bit of other stuff you know the
stuff about wages and then we're reading
the communist manifesto and the other
thing that we're reading that I haven't
taught before but I've been interested
in for quite a while is a book that many
of you probably don't know about it's by
Johan Huizinga who is a sort of
historian of ideas it's called Homo
Luden's the play element and culture so
I thought again for artists that could
be quite useful to go into so that's a
lot of talking about what we're doing in
the classes let me look at some of the
questions that people have been asking
the greeter any tips on how new students
should approach philosophical texts
concerning annotations etc you know one
of the things that I actually do provide
my students with is a video that I shot
years and years ago when I was teaching
face-to-face for Marist how to read a
philosophical text and there is no
recipe for it there's multiple
approaches that a person can take but
you know you here's the one thing you
can definitely say every philosophical
text don't expect to to you know fully
understand everything that you're
reading the first time through so you
don't stop until you've like figured out
exactly what's happening in this chapter
you keep on moving through and then you
can start going back and reading it more
closely as a matter of fact I would
actually suggest the first time through
not taking notes on it
just reading it through and seeing what
you you make of it if you come out and
you're like man I don't understand a
single thing I read in here that's
that's probably a problem but if you've
understood some things you can build off
of that annotations if that's up to you
know the student some people like to
take lots of notes in their books I I
don't I underline sometimes and I may
write a few words I used to write longer
passages until I realized I probably
wasn't going to go back and read them
and take account of them so but if
you're doing that that's fine and you
know you should probably expect not to
sell your books back if you're taking a
philosophy class because if the
instructors good and they've picked out
you know decent selections these are
books you want to keep for a while
daniel asks how do you broach the topic
of explaining your YouTube channel and
online presence to your students how do
they typically react when they found
about your a Fame well you know like I
say there's two famous famous and
there's YouTube famous sort of its
little brother right I you know I tell
them right at the start and it's in so I
you know I create these these course
shells you could call them I use the
course management system to create a
pretty extensive
course website and the website will
probably have videos in it if I'm
teaching an online class I'm using my
own videos if I'm teaching a
face-to-face class I use videos as
resources and sometimes I actually do
lecture capture where I video record
class sessions and then upload them into
the learning management system sort of
like what I did with with Maris with the
YouTube but but just in just for those
students right there and you know I tell
them about that and the starts
especially if there's gonna be a camera
they want to know what the hell that
that's for and they like having the
stuff recorded because it's it's useful
for them and then you know I'll have a
page where I talk about like what it is
that I do and I'll usually have a link
to the YouTube channel there some of my
students already know about my youtube
channel by the time that they come in
and that may in fact depending on the
place be one of the reasons why they may
have signed up for my classes so that
that you know happens every once in
awhile and they don't usually have any
problem with it where I usually get
people having a negative attitude about
it our older colleagues and sometimes
younger you know professor colleagues
they sometimes don't like it you know
they I think they view it as the basing
philosophy or something like that or
maybe that maybe they feel a little you
know confused or threatened by it I
don't know you'd have to ask them dr.
Phil you ever read Thomas Brown any
thoughts if I have I don't remember
reading himself could be something that
I read back in college but I don't
remember Marcos do you use the Socratic
method style of teaching Thanks well yes
and no I think a lot of people think
that the Socratic style method means
that and they're taking this from some
of the early dialogues where Socrates
says I know that I know nothing right
which is BS he
he knows a lot of stuff that's very
clear in the dialogues you just got a
little sort of read between the lines
and you see here that he knows all sorts
of things and quite often the knowing
what he doesn't know doesn't mean that
he doesn't know anything but the notion
of question and answer right asking
pointed questions to try to evoke
something from the student that was
Socratic now Socrates usually tried to
get the student to go somewhere and in
many of the dialogues that is what
happens so Socratic questioning
strictly speaking doesn't mean just
asking open-ended questions and not
supplying any any viewpoints of your own
or assumptions of your own but I think a
lot of people do that and I always find
that a little bit pretentious and you
know it's kind of a dead end if you
don't if you don't actually have any
commitments you know to start with
there's not much that you can build upon
I think and that's that's a bit of a
problem so yeah I mean I I do use a lot
of back and forth dialogue and dialectic
we use a lot of examples that was
something else Socrates is very fond of
and we try to work our way towards some
sort of better understanding of things
now do I I'm not a big trying to attain
a definition kind of guy but other
people you know I think view that as
part of the Socratic thing all right
daniel has another one what's the first
day like in one of your classes do you
have a typical ship Elia give your
students on the first day or more
dependent on the class oh there's so
there are some common elements I mean we
go over the syllabus I make my
expectations and requirements clear to
them inevitably I'm answering some
questions that they have about
assignments another thing you can say is
half the students aren't listening when
you're doing that because they'll ask
you the same questions later on
and you know we talk about the
discipline of philosophy and I do that
in fact you have to give a pep talk to
many of my students because they haven't
had any philosophy prior to that and
they often come in quite anxious and
intimidated by being in a philosophy
class and they think it's going to be
very difficult and very abstract and
that they're going to have a hard time
with it and that they may not be up to
understanding it so I do give them a pep
talk and the pep talk is more or less
along the lines of every one of you can
in fact study Plato or Aristotle or
Cicero or you know Han Arendt or whoever
you may not get every single thing
that's going on in the text but that's
ok because even us experts don't get
everything out of the text and you know
what you have to do is be willing to put
in the work I will provide you with
helpful resources we will have these
class sessions to try to work through
some of these matters and then you know
then we do get into some things specific
to the particular class so if it's an
ethics class we're gonna talk about
what's the nature of ethics right in the
philosophies of human nature class we're
gonna talk about you know this notion of
human nature and what what it could
possibly mean and if I'm if I'm teaching
a particular batch of students you know
like with the my add students
professional students it's up to me to
make the connection to the disciplines
that they are there to study their
majors so we also you know do some back
and forth about what the nature of their
their discipline is and how philosophy
could enter into it they're what it
might have to say and so that's that's
important as well alright a lot of
questions already here's a good question
from zakir anderson where would you
recommend starting with eastern
philosophy start by not calling it
eastern philosophy start by realizing
that there's a Chinese sort of culture
tradition and an Indian culture
tradition that
developed independently of each other
and that each one of them is incredibly
rich there are connections between them
particularly you know once Buddhism
crosses the Himalayas but they really
are you know each of them is distinct
from each other as each of them is from
say Western philosophy right and realize
that Islamic philosophy kind of you know
straddles this field you know it's
really closer to what's going on in
Western philosophy now if you're I
always say start at the beginning right
I mean so we look at the older texts
that we have and then we move on from
there I guess you know with Chinese
philosophy if you want to say that
there's like a Socratic moment in it you
know meaning that there's like a guy who
you would start with you really cannot
stuck with to you know loud Sun and
Confucius and we don't really know where
the louts are wrote the daodejing or not
but we're gonna say that he did write
and Confucius we don't have stuff that
he wrote but we have the the Analects
and then we have the Confucian classics
which are compiled by later confusions
but that's where we got to start right
and in Indian philosophy I mean starting
with the Vedas is not a bad idea but you
got to do a lot of explaining otherwise
students are like what the hell is this
otherwise maybe you should go right into
the pan of sheds so yeah and then you
know you got to figure out what you're
going to pack in well and you didn't ask
about this question but I'll just
mention this when you're teaching a
class one of the biggest challenges in
initially designing the class is
figuring out what you're going to put
into the class and what things you're
going to unfortunately have to exclude
so you know we'd love to teach so much
more things than than we do but we don't
get the opportunity to do that because
we have to cram everything into this 15
week semester or format or sometimes
some of my classes are
weeks and so you can't cover everything
that you would like to you know that's
that's part of why I like designing my
own classes in my teachable Academy
because there if I think that a class
needs this many modules then we do that
you know you know think about like when
you try to cram a book like Heidegger's
being in time or Hegel's you know
phenomenology into a 15 week semester it
doesn't it doesn't neatly fit you know
all right
pro pho um I've got a question about
your book on the French debates I wanted
to read it with my dad and maybe some
other Christians but I'm the only one
read on philosophy do you think they'll
get lost
um yeah you know there's probably a good
chance that they would that some of the
articles are pretty technical and you
know responding to each other and you
know they're they're they're presuming a
certain philosophical milieu but there's
you know I wrote about a hundred page
introduction to it at the beginning of
the text and so that can be useful for
some background I think I've always
thought it'd be kind of a cool thing to
write up you know a more popular work
that's grappling with those debates and
and other questions that they were
involving and you know aiming at a more
general audience than that then that
volume is aimed at but I haven't had the
time to do that Francis what is the true
value of intellectual life if not an
expanded perspective how can it be
intrinsically rewarding and edifying
even when it's purely theoretical well I
don't think that there is a single true
value of an intellectual life I think
that there's multiple values and one
person might enjoy several of them one
person may be drawn only to one of them
and sometimes it changes
course of your career or your life so an
expanded perspective that's great you
know some people can be happy with
purely theoretical inquiry all right
and then some of us are much more
practically inclined and wanting to know
okay how would this play out what are
its practical implications or how can we
apply this so I don't see those as as
mutually exclusive and I think
individuals often have to choose between
them but I don't think as a fielder as a
community that we all have to choose
between them
do I think the principle of sufficient
reason is valid throughout if not why
I'm not sure what valid throughout is
supposed to mean you know do you mean
applying to everything applying to all
phenomena you know or are you talking
about the principle itself you know all
right dr. Phil it seems like many other
students can't think outside the the
prism of race and gender what are your
thoughts on this yeah so if you can't
think outside of the prism of race and
gender that is a pretty confining
straightjacket because there's a hell of
a lot more that makes us who we are and
that divides us also than just those two
things
and I think what you have in mind is
people who are sort of tribalist in that
they think about everything through the
the issue of issues of race and gender
so they they would say you know things
like well you know you need to be
reading women authors because otherwise
you can't get a woman's perspective
about things you know that that's
intrinsically valuable and and you know
or you know why is philosophy so white
or all of these sorts of things that
come up from time to time
and you know these are these are
questions worth asking and exploring I
don't think that that the answer to
those issues coming up is to try to cut
them off I think it's you explore them
fully and show that there's multiple
perspectives within let's say we just
take gender right so you know you teach
somebody like Hannah Arendt and you say
all right what would how to rent make of
contemporary feminist critiques of
things that are really really you know
gynocentric and you know a rent was with
somebody who's very conscious of like
you know Aristotle's boneheaded comments
about women but I rent and I rent was
you know brilliant thinker and a rent is
is also somebody who would probably not
buy into anything like well you know
just putting a woman into a position is
automatically going to you know fix the
philosophical problem so we got to just
hire a lot of a lot of women professors
she would say that's nonsense you know
so but what you do is you then have them
read a rent and you know have a rent so
to speak talk to them and we can say
similar things about race I mean I think
it's it's it's important to talk about
race and I do in like my classes but we
don't want to reduce everything to race
particularly since it's not it's not a
real thing anyway it's it's essentially
a social construct and the same ideas
don't mean the same thing from country
to country or culture to culture that's
odd to you know there are people doing
that in terms of ooh you know people who
who lured the Western tradition or or
things like that and they do so
essentially in the name of a white
nationalism that would be denounced by
many of the people who they're
highlighting I mean Cicero
it would take you know just a few looks
or Aristotle take a few looks at the
people who put them up on a pedestal and
talk about that as being you know white
culture and say sorry buddy
I'm not getting on your train you know
and there's there's there's so much more
so I mean we do get we do get a good bit
of that coming from from different sides
um Ryan will you speak of your interest
in Deleuze especially the concept of the
rhizome or the blending of form and
content well I'm not interested in the
rhizome quite frankly I'm not very
interested in Toulouse he's somebody who
I read a good bit of back in graduate
school and and the rereading that I do
have to lose is primarily just his his
history of philosophy texts and his is
you know I think if si is critical and
clinically and I'd say is katikut clean
meek which I find very interesting but
most of the other stuff I I'm not very
interested in it and I'm not very
interested in delusions that's part of
what helped it turn me off from Deleuze
was the fact that people just keep
talking rhizome rhizome rhizome this is
a rhizome that's a rhizome this is a
rhizome and after a while you know
you're like you know some things aren't
actually rhizomes and they're not just
you know oppressive power structures by
not being rhizomes we don't always make
everything rhizomatic for its own sake
and so you know that's probably enough
about to lose Francis do you do I think
that it will someday be possible to
obtain a complete rational knowledge of
all of existence including the knowledge
of how existence came into being yeah I
mean it's certainly possible I mean I
actually believe that there's at least
one being that actually has that
knowledge and I think any any theist
would have to say that's the case what
you mean though is is it possible for us
human beings to have that sort of
knowledge
and maybe not I mean it's interesting
even somebody like like Thomas Aquinas
right he talks about what the Blessed in
heaven get to get to see and you think
about it you got eternity to see stuff
and you have no impediments anymore and
he says that he's in the treatise on law
the Blessed in heaven get to see the
eternal law which is which is God itself
and God's relation to all the rest of
the universe but they don't comprehend
it so they don't fully get all of it at
the same time but you know way more than
we do so can we make progress towards
that sort of thing yeah and and you know
I think there's a danger when we worry
about these sorts of things of winding
up in a kind of despair so alright Ryan
asks have I ever been to China no I have
not as a matter of fact I've only been
in the United States Canada and a few
countries in Europe I have never been to
South America I've never been to Africa
I've never been to Asia
I've never been to Australia I haven't
been to a lot of places
Orion as a follow-up what do you make
what do I make of China even if I have
not been there I'm considering a
graduate program in philosophy there
well I mean that could be good
certainly is a smart career move because
China is going to be incredibly
important geopolitically for the rest of
our existence unless there's some really
dramatic change of affairs that's part
of why I decided and teaching the non
Western philosophy to focus on a little
bit of Chinese philosophy because I
think it's good to have like a little
bit of cultural background in that sort
of stuff
I actually did include in the earlier
version of the syllabus the hon fates so
you know a little bit of the legalist
radition
but i had to drop it out you know that
triage that we have to do I would say
you know if you're gonna go on to
graduate program in China there are some
practical considerations you know make
sure you've got your visas and stuff
like that done way ahead of time
especially I mean if I don't know if
you're here in the States but Trump
keeps stirring up can a Hornet nest with
the Chinese so you want to make sure
you've got everything approved a long
time in advance and you know expect to
deal with especially if you're in like a
major city incredible levels of
pollution that like I know I would not I
probably would not be able to handle the
levels of pollution talking with people
who've been in China and just like the
toll it takes on your lungs and stuff
like that so you know it would it be a
great opportunity yeah but you got to
make sure you're up for it
renew what do I think Russo would think
about the state of television shows and
movie theaters today well he'd probably
think they're you know not a hell of a
lot better but not a hell of a lot worse
than they were 50 years ago I think he'd
think that all of that is kind of drivel
right and people get very captivated
with shows you know the notion of sort
of like fandom people who would would
actually care about what happened in
this episode and then like go to a
convention and ask the creator about it
about continuities and things like that
I think Rousseau would say that's that's
an example of like people getting really
worked up about the wrong things in in
civilization but you know I mean result
we use these a let's get back to nature
let's get at least get back to savagery
kind of person or let's move ahead into
some sort of social contract in general
we'll I don't think that that he would
he would see contemporary television as
particularly helpful for that Pro home
you read many atheist philosophers
nature and Heidegger you are religious
out of this influence your faith
I mean here's a thing I don't read them
as atheists because I also don't read
theists as theists I'm interested in the
ideas that they have and what they bring
to the table and there's quite frankly a
lot of theists who I think are just a
waste of time and I wouldn't wouldn't
bother reading and there's plenty of
atheists or agnostics for that matter or
members of other religions who I think
are very interesting and had things to
say and and I'm not you know the only
person along those lines think about
again Thomas Aquinas he would try to
incorporate everybody he could that's
the old dialectical method that
Aristotle produced you know and and I
think that that's what you do as a
philosopher you you know does Nietzsche
have stuff to say that's useful for say
a Christian perspective like the stuff
about resentiment mock Schaller
certainly thought so that's why you hold
wrote a whole book called rose on time'
and there he says well Nietzsche got
this part right there's a great insight
and then he went too far with this part
and so that's that's essentially what
you do
[Music]
alright so daniel has a question that
I'm not going to try even like try to
answer why do I believe Jesus was
literally resurrected from the dead
historical support philosophical
argument how would you convince someone
of this if you were hypothetically
interested in doing so I wouldn't I'm
not an apologist you know and I think
that when it comes to most of the stuff
that we end up believing in it's rarely
through like you know some syllogistic
philosophical argument or accumulation
of data and facts it's always through
some interpretive lens and a lot of that
has to do with personal connections with
other people and seeing you know what
living that that mode of life actually
does for them and and you can't you know
universalize from that but I have long
since quit worrying about being an
apologist I just worry about my own
practice and how far away from where I
would like to be I actually am so yeah
it's not not much of an issue for me
oh just jumped over a bunch of stuff let
me scroll back up here we go
August says do you have a mandatory non
major class for example my college had a
mandatory ethics class is a problem
because there's 400 level and necessary
for graduation so I don't personally
have it such a class but the places that
I teach sometimes do so yeah you know I
teach online from Marist College and the
class that I teach is required for the
School of Professional Professional
Studies students it's called world views
and values and it's basically an intro
class and Marquette's foundations in
philosophy class is foundations for a
philosophy class is also essentially an
intro class again with like I said with
a few bells and whistles thrown in you
know you're supposed to be teaching
philosophical methodology in a thematic
way and you're supposed to emphasize
different perspectives but it really
comes down to teaching an intro class
ethics was required at Marquette and
it's no longer required for the incoming
students but it was required and I was
teaching it who knows maybe they'll ask
me to teach it again and now the the
other class that I'm teaching
yeah well the business ethics I don't
know if that's actually required for a
business major I should probably check
on that
should be you know it's your if they're
trying to claim to at the Jesuit school
alright but it may not be and for the my
ad class I'm teaching an elective it is
a humanities elective they have to take
it to humanities electives but nobody
says which ones they have to take
you know these are what we call service
classes and the service classes are good
they're a great opportunity to actually
engage with people who are not there
primarily to take philosophy but to do
something else and they're usually the
one chance that we have to make a good
case for our discipline and lay down a
groundwork that students might be able
to use later on in their life so for me
that that's something I take very
seriously at all admit I'd probably
didn't take it as seriously at the start
but now I see how important that is yeah
you know colleges should have mandatory
philosophy classes I think and colleges
that try to cut back on the core and
humanities I think are doing a
disservice to their students I
understand the motives that that people
have for doing so it's usually because
they don't understand why an ethics
class is important themselves or they
think it's something you can sort of
pick up on the fly
and I would say that it's important to
have literature classes and history
classes and in other classes as well but
that's a tough sell
and once here's the other thing I'll say
once you shrink the core once you no
longer make a class required you're
never gonna get it back into the books
again not the way education was going
these days so you're better off holding
the line even if it's not an ideal line
then then letting you know anything get
get phased out all right dough's
expanses thanks for all your videos I'm
trying to teach myself as I never went
to college
as I get older and angrier I realize I
need something well the videos can be
useful for that remember the videos are
not a substitute for reading the texts
you really want to read and study these
classic texts you shouldn't just you
know watch a video or listen to a
podcast sooner or later
you
want to give yourself the opportunity to
actually see what Plato had to say or
Augustine or you know Hana rent or
Nietzsche or whoever whoever it happens
to be
uh Engel is a how to read a book
properly you know like the right way not
upside down I mean there's no one single
proper way to read a book it's way more
complicated than that char and how does
stoic see pride do they have pride in
the way of how they're living well that
was certainly the verdict of people like
say Pascal right and and Augustine and
locked on CS and all these other
Christian thinkers they did think the
Stoics were prideful you know the I
don't know that it would be so much
about pride but there's certainly a joy
that you see the Stoics advocating in
like attaining the the measure of
freedom and virtue that you do develop
right pride in the sense of like
thinking that you're better than other
people really wouldn't be very stoic and
if you read you know the classic stoic
authors you'll see that they say you
know I'm not as good as soand scar I'm
not better than everybody else you know
doing whatever my opinions on Spinoza
Spinoza is interesting
he's not somebody who I'm particularly
fascinated with but you know I've taught
him before and I'll actually be working
on some Spinoza with a client later this
fall and you know he's certainly worth
reading so am i into poetry is anime a
girl yeah I mean that's why I'm teaching
rilco but I have to admit I don't read a
lot of poet
tree you know I don't unfortunately I
know that much time and in order to read
poetry well you've gotta like you gotta
actually set aside time so that you can
you can think it through any favorite
poems poets yeah I mean Homer right
the dramatic poets but I really I really
am a big fan of Rilke and I don't get
much time to read other people used to
read on you know some of these other
people that you know for me poetry if
it's interesting it's it's probably
going to be because it's got some sort
of metaphysical import right all right
what did I think in general what do I
think of philosophy in the mirror of
nature Oh Rory that's okay
people were really wild about that book
when it first came out and now you know
oh yeah
we're we're not able to be naive
realists and vitka stein and and Derrida
Dewey and Heidegger we're doing similar
projects okay
you know I mean I think a you know it's
interesting that there's a lot of times
there's books that are able to make a
huge impact just because of how narrow
the field is at that time and I think
that was the case for for Rory's work
[Music]
August yes do you know any philosophers
that specialize in on read Berg stone or
some works I've already read Barracks
onanism the creative mind creative
evolution and matter and memory no no I
mean to go back to the Deleuze thing to
lose is a big you know guy on baritone
but well every time you read to lose on
some philosopher you're getting more to
lose than that philosopher no I I don't
you know I don't know I don't read a lot
of secondary literature so
and I add I don't get around to reading
baritone very much although I do enjoy
them and I have a whole bunch of his
works in French on my shelf that I don't
get around to Pushkin is it necessary to
read Hegel to understand Marx probably
not actually my Kurt you can't hurt but
it depends on what you're gonna read you
know there are some mark CND's who will
tell you the opposite that oh if you
want to understand Marx you have to have
this background Hegel but then they kind
of did different on what Hegel you need
to read and how to interpret hegel hegel
certainly didn't didn't use the you know
Hegelian three-step that Marxists are so
incredibly fond of with you know thesis
antithesis synthesis it throughout all
of his works you're almost never going
to find that in the phenomenology for
example although you you know you will
find a lot more triadic stuff in the
lectures and in the science of logic but
you know in order to understand key
ideas of Marx do you need to read Hegel
probably not
you know because Marx is doing his own
thing with it anyway all right King Olli
what is your opinion on this popular
political philosophers like Harris
Peterson or Maloney oh you know I don't
take Molyneux seriously at all Harris
and Peterson you know I understand a lot
of people like them a lot of people like
Mullen you too
but you know when I've when I've seen
them talk as Mullen you especially
you're like man there's so many holes
and in that and and you know you didn't
really you don't get the sense that
they've really understood a lot of the
things that especially text that they're
they're working with I talked about this
before I think Peterson is in some
respect a prisoner of his own success
once you start mixing into these
political things and you become a
darling of
this group or that group it's very
difficult to resist the temptation to
start saying the sorts of things and
thinking the sort of things that will
keep you in that that spotlight so yeah
I mean it'll be interesting will will
they be looked at a hundred years from
now as important figures or will just as
few people read them as read Herbert
Spencer you know in in in our time you
might say well who the hell's this
Herbert Spencer exactly but he was big
stuff back in his time and you know he
was kind of saying some of the same
stuff that you know some of these people
are Lord of the universe reading some
Plato I came from a sociology background
can't help think that Plato got bogged
down where their abstractions exist or
not and did not think about it as a tool
to help us think well okay
Plato is probably smarter than that you
know I mean reads more Plato
that's roughly the answer to that I mean
you're never gonna find the word
abstraction in Plato right you so you
have to think about what is he actually
talking about I mean didn't think of
abstractions as a tool to help us think
what do you think the forms do I mean if
you've read like the the Republic the
philosopher Kings they look to the forms
to the patterns to help them figure out
how to solve practical problems in the
present by moving things closer to the
forms so there's one instance right
there where he is doing that alright to
do we skipped up a bit more looks like
there's a lot of back and forth about
Deleuze here
iMacs 25a do I believe knowing pro kleh
in deep is necessary to read Aquinas
nope
Aristotle be more necessary for learn
you know reading Aquinas
Agustina be more necessary ProQuest
probably not pair obeys Otzi own
thoughts on critical theory depends on
what you mean by critical for you if
you're talking about the Frankfurt
School
I found them quite interesting if you're
talking about critical theory more
broadly the way that literary people use
it I think a lot of it is just fluff and
we're not gonna you know pay attention
to it years from now even some of the
front for it school stuff that can I do
quite frankly alright let's see what we
got here is a lot of back and forth
about Deleuze and barracks own okay roll
robos 121 thoughts about distributive
ISM and Belloc and Chesterton in general
so I'm a huge fan of Chesterton I like
Chesterton's works I find his his you
know when he's not just like playing
with words and being paradoxical for its
own sake he actually shows a lot of
insight distributive ISM for those who
don't know it's sort of like that you
can think of it as like a Catholic
social theory and economic theory that
was being advocated by you know some of
the turn-of-the-century Catholics every
once in a while you'll see people
advocating it today pretty much a
non-starter I don't think you're ever
going to get the conditions for that to
really happen except you could do it
locally but I don't think you know it's
got almost no traction whatsoever
outside of certain Catholic circles so
I'm not even sure what to make of this
one Inglot say philosophy looks like it
lost its scientific methods nowaday
philosophy just bunch of text but I
guess 100 years later philosophy will
gain its scientific methods because of
political science maybe I don't know I
don't think
and Sciences is an equivocal term it
means a lot of different things on a lot
of different contexts it's in a balk I
think of myself as an ethical eclectic
but I often don't know how to reconcile
different schools of moral philosophy in
real life do you have this problem
sometime how do you deal with that
that's a good question so if you are an
eclectic then you know there's a couple
different ways to do it
you could try to synthesize these
theories as wholes and that's not going
to work the only way you can do that is
by lying to yourself and telling telling
yourself that they're all saying the
same thing which is not the case
oftentimes another sort of extreme
position would be like eclecticism where
you just like pick out a little bit of
this a little bit of this and a little
bit of this and the danger with that is
you're you're really just doing what
satisfies you and so there's you know
there's a tendency to pick the the
doctrines that you like the best right
but you know when it comes down to it on
important moral matters what you can do
that is you can think of
philosophical perspectives that you're
finding in moral theory asur like having
some really intelligent friends there to
advise you it'd be you still have to
ultimately make the decision yourself
and so you get their advice and you see
what they have to say and then you have
to make your own judgment on it and
follow through on that decision and
assume the consequences and
responsibility for it and that's about
as good as it gets
you know all right I've got about four
minutes left before I got to go walk the
dogs let's see what we we got here we
got a bunch of different things I don't
know which ones I can effectively get to
[Music]
well here's a good one anonymous 97 do
you think the IQ test is a good tool to
test human intelligence in very limited
ways for
very limited purposes I think that
anybody who thinks that IQ tests
actually tell us about intelligence per
se may have a high IQ but isn't very
intelligent and a lot of people love it
because you know they they think that it
its objective and you can use it to as a
proxy for all sorts of stuff but man
there's a lot of dumb people with high
IQs out there so so it doesn't really
work that way
Oh Richard I think philosophers should
be able to teach reading as well as
anybody in the literature Department
what do you say well what makes you
think that the people in the literature
department can teach reading well to
begin with a lot of them are very
narrowly specialized and you know maybe
enamored of this methodology or that
methodology and may not may not actually
be good to teachers that said sound like
they have monopoly on that and it's not
like philosophers don't often fit into
that as well and a lot of philosophers
unfortunately read very very very very
narrowly you know and they I don't know
that they could teach literature very
well the other thing too is philosophers
are always on the lookout for the
argument the claim they want to
challenge people and sometimes they're
unable to actually read something and
just see what it's what it's saying and
then sort of you know let it sort of
percolate and you know Mull it over for
a while
somebody by the way who was a huge
reader of literature and you know was a
philosopher GE Moore it was actually
like his guilty pleasure reading
literature alright to do let's see what
we got here and see if I can go out on a
bang with something here we go
from from August do I find it easier to
read a philosophical dialogue or an ass
I've been revisiting Plato and the
dialogue has been harder for me to
understand than if I were to read
Aristotle it depends very much on who's
writing the dialogue you know there's a
lot of dialogues that are not real
dialogues because they're basically just
a treatise with oh yes so-and-so thrown
in there a genuine dialogue should have
some points of you know confusion and
the learner is led somewhere or they
should have some points of contention
that's why you know Plato's dialogues
are usually real dialogues as are our
Cicero's as our Anselm's as our you know
we can go on and on and on but that
sometimes makes them more difficult you
know Plato part of what makes it
difficult is that he uses what I think
he knows are bad arguments at some
points and puts them in Socrates mouth
and the question that is well why the
hell would he do that
maybe it's um you know to make us think
about those those arguments and how we
could improve them maybe he's sucking us
into the dialogue by doing so so on that
I'm going to say great session
didn't gets all the questions but I
tried to get the most of them and hope
all of you guys have a good day or
evening or midnight or work whatever it
is wherever you happen to be and yeah
I'll do another one of these on Facebook
live a little bit later in the month and
talk more about what I'm going to be
teaching I think that'll happen before
my classes start so alright see you
later